if you've ever wondered where your mutt
came from or what health issues your dog
might run into down the line you're not
alone
embark is a dog dna testing company that
made it onto forbes next billion dollar
startups list this year the company was
started by ryan boyco a canine
geneticist and his younger brother adam
who has a master's degree in public
health i was interested in dog genetics
about eight years before i founded the
company i started a project with my
brother actually to
go around the world and
collect dna from dogs around the world
so we could better understand where they
came from how they spread across the
globe because they are
this unique bond they have this unique
bond with people you can go on our
website or amazon chewy places like that
order a test and it'll show up at your
door and then it's just a simple
cheek swab so for 30 seconds you swab
your dog's cheek there's instructions
videos all of that
to make it easy drop it in the mailer
that we we provide and in about two to
three weeks you'll get your results so
you get an email that says your results
are ready
there's the health results and then the
breed results and
and then even after that
we update you with new relatives for
your dog sometimes add new health tests
and and all of that
to understand the biggest problems that
afflict dogs um you know cancers and hip
dysplasia all of that you really need a
million or more dogs in a database so
that you can
find these complex genetic associations
it's not just one gene it's many genes
coming together
and
there just wasn't money
available via academic channels to build
that kind of database of dogs you know
that
you could maybe get a few thousand dogs
and at the same time we saw 23andme's
success in the market and we we also saw
as we tried to
recruit dogs for these studies that
my brother was doing in his lab that
lots and lots of people were like yes i
want to do this and what else can you
tell me about my dog and the answer was
well
we're in academic lab we can't really
tell you anything about our dog all of
that kind of came together and coalesced
in this idea that we could provide
people with actionable information now
with interesting information now we
could provide breeders with tools that
would actually help breed longer-lived
healthier dogs right now and at the same
time be building a database of
information that's going to allow us to
make discoveries that help dogs live
longer
in the future
the company launched in 2015. this year
they expect to make 72 million dollars
in revenue up nearly 50 percent from 50
million last year breeders for one um
you know use us as part of a core part
of their breeding program so of course
they
are in some ways these artists
essentially who are trying to
breed a dog for some purpose whether
it's to be the ideal family pet or to
win westminster or to be a great herding
dog whatever it is
but underlying all of that is
the need for dogs that are healthy dogs
that live a long time
and so this is really a tool where
they can take all the other tools that
they do to breed for
for those things while using us to make
sure they're also doing that in in light
of what would make the healthiest dog
about a third of our users say that
after they get
our results a third of you know just
average pet owners
when they get our results say they
change at least something about their
dog's care routine whether it's diet or
exercise or training or toys or whatever
it is
and many of the things that we do test
for most of the health conditions we
find in dogs
there is something that you can do
whether you know from changing diet to
changing the environment
to that kind of thing in order to reduce
their risk
ryan says they stand apart because they
test more thoroughly than other dna kits
on the market about three years ago now
we launched the first ever canine
relative finder you know dogs are born
together in a litter usually those
siblings and parents are in the same
geographic area
and so in lots of cases people decide to
meet up and they have these amazing
stories of their you know their dogs
meet and they seem to already know each
other and and play and all of that
the company is worth around 700 million
dollars and is looking at how to use its
growing genomic database to improve
canine health and longevity as it grows
we are in this for the dogs at the same
time
we have
had conversations with companies that
are really interested in human health
and there are
definitely conditions because they've
shared our environment for so long and
they you know share
certain traits with us
where they are a really really good
model for them
in a human sense so the idea here though
is they're not we would never use
dogs
as research subjects like rats in the
lab or something we would be trying to
help dog health and a nice byproduct of
that could be that some of the advances
made in dog health may be able to be
translated into human medicine as well
we
one believe that the test should become
the standard of care for all dogs you
know things like predisposition to get
bladder stones where you can feed the
dog a different diet and avoid that
instead of
now what happens is you learn it the
hard way basically when your dog is in a
lot of pain and unable to urinate and
you have to take them to an emergency
vet and it's both painful and costly to
learn that information and here you can
learn it much more cheaply and actually
do something about it before it becomes
a problem
you